a virginia school board
has just voted to approve
some true radicalism there was a
proposal put forward to this virginia
school board to fly another flag next to
the american flag at all of their
schools that other flag is the blm flag
blm is a marxist organization that says
that the united states is intrinsically
oppressive and unjust and bigoted that
seeks total revolution in the united
states and this virginia school board
just voted to fly the two flags side by
side
the board approves the student's request
to fly the black lives matter flag and
the board will review this matter
annually in alignment with the equity
policy
all right
so um
i guess if it's clear i could do it and
all those in favor raise hands and then
if we
have lack of clarity
do the roll call is that okay i'm sorry
this shouldn't be that complicated but
okay so all those in favor of the motion
signify by raising your hand and alan i
can see
so it is three against
six in favor
and
um so the flag will continue to fly
so the flag is going to fly okay
we are now going to have the blm flag
fly next to the american flag but the
blm flag opposes the american flag
there's a contradiction here the blm
movement really got off the ground
because people started protesting the
american flag on football fields in a
lot of other places
so these are contradictory symbols
and i bet you if you asked liberals
around america
which flag do you more identify with if
you ask real real
activists leftists and liberals which
flag do you more identify with the blm
flag or the american flag i bet most of
them would tell you the blm flag
beyond blm if you showed a flag the lgbt
the rainbow flag or the new rainbow flag
where there's a bunch of races in it you
know like black is now a sexual
orientation or something that flag or
the american flag which do you identify
more with i would bet that most ardent
leftist and liberal activists would tell
you the rainbow flag
flags are important
words are important i wrote a whole book
about this called speechless controlling
words controlling minds the left
reshapes the culture through
symbols and words in particular words
are just symbols
flags are signs of conquest okay that's
that's why conquering armies carry flags
and standards they're a sign of hegemony
this is what we stand for and so when
the left reshapes all of our symbols
the left is totally reshaping the
country this should not be permitted we
should use our politics to stop this we
should ban the flying of these radical
flags that oppose america
next to the american flag we should ban
the flying of them in our schools and
our public buildings entirely there is a
bit this is what there was a big fight
over the rainbow flag at u.s embassies
what do we stand for if we stand for the
red white and blue truth justice in the
american way you're going to rally a lot
of americans to your cause if we stand
for pride flags flying in kandahar
you're going to have more and more and
more division you're going to have more
and more strife you're going to have an
abolition of the traditional american
nation
i'm glad that you liked that clip
i like that you like that clip
if you want to get more clips you got to
ring that bell you got to subscribe get
the notifications if you don't get the
notifications for whatever reason
youtube
then you should head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
podcast leave a five-star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you